[Musique]
tandis que les manifestations se
poursuivent à travers le monde après le
meurtre de george floyd beaucoup se
demandent si le mouvement politique qui
s'en est suivi pourraient mener à de
véritables changements voire à une
révolution et nous avons avec nous dans
notre émission une femme qui sait très
bien à quel point il est difficile de
lutter contre l'oppression systématique
et le capitalisme radicale la légendaire
black panther et militante la
professeure angela davis face à sa lutte
pour l'égalité dans les années 60 et 70
le président richard nixon avait
qualifié de dangereuse terroristes elle
toujours à par skype depuis oakland en
californie
merci de vous joindre à nous dans notre
émission madame la professeure
voilà ce que je voudrais vous demander
pour commencer on voit beaucoup de
citations de james baldwin un grand
écrivain qui d'ailleurs a écrit une
lettre ouverte qui vous étaient
adressées il a 10 de nos corps nous
devons rendre infranchissable le couloir
vers la chambre à gaz
quand on est il par là bien sûr
james baldwin n'était pas seulement un
grand écrivain
il était aussi impliqué dans toutes
sortes de combat pour la justice sociale
et il s'est penché sur mon cas il m'a
écrit une lettre ouverte
il disait que s'il ne protégeait pas ma
vie ils seraient les suivantes
s'ils viennent vous chercher un matin 10
et il est si nous ne les empêcherons pas
de vous arrêter
alors nous serons alors les suivants
selon lui c'est là l'idée même des
mouvements sociaux fait que ce soit
contre le racisme contre la misogynie
contre le changement climatique
l'injustice et cetera à cause ses
paroles d'un très fort écho de nos jours
à cause de l'emploi de l'expression
chambres à gaz dans l'état de californie
il y a toujours une chambre à gaz qui se
trouvent dans la prison de cinquante ans
il ya eu de nombreuses manifestations
surtout ces derniers temps parce que les
prisons favorisent la propagation du
copie
la ville d'auckland où vous vous trouvez
maintenant est considéré dans le monde
entier comme un lieu assez progressistes
heures
néanmoins dépenses une énorme part de
son budget pour la police et les
activités de cette dernière
que pensez vous que baldwin voulait dire
lorsqu'il affirmait qu on pouvait juger
de la santé d'une nation en regardant
les personnes qu'elle est l'icône
représentant au défenseur quel est
l'état de santé de votre nation
aujourd'hui je pense que le monde peut
voir que cette nation est loin d'être
saine que nos services de police sont la
manifestation la plus dramatique du
racisme structurel faut que nos prisons
sont pleines de noir et de latino
américains nous devons adopter une
mentalité abolitionniste si nous voulons
garantir l'avenir de notre ville de
notre état de notre pays du monde entier
nous reviendrons plus tard sur
l'abolition du complexe carcéral
industrielle et de la police bien
évidemment vous avez été la cible du fbi
ya de toute évidence les gens qui
travaillent dans les médias savent ce
qu'est le watergate
est-ce que cela prendra beaucoup plus de
temps selon vous pour qu'ils apprennent
quelque chose concernant qu une telle
preuve de plus en plus de gens se
rendent compte de comment le
gouvernement essayer d'éliminer tous
ceux qui résistaient ceux qui incarnent
est réellement le potentiel futur de la
démocratie dans ce pays
il faut généralement beaucoup de temps
pour que de vrais changements commencent
pour qu'ils aient lieu par ailleurs il
ya des moments comme la conjoncture
actuelle et intègre un large spectre de
lutte et dangereux jeu
omar et tous ceux qui ont été actifs qui
ont lutté contre le racisme la
patriarchie et l'oppression économique
depuis des amis à voir que en fin de
compte notre travail porte ses fruits
même si 10 ans 20 ans 30 ans 40 ans 50
ans ont passé avant qu'on puisse voir
les fruits de ses efforts certains de
nos spectateurs ne savent peut-être pas
à ce qu est qu une telle pro
pourriez-vous nous raconter comment le
fbi a il vous a persécuté
en ce moment on peut lire que trump fait
aussi l'objet de persécutions du fbi et
bien j'étais sur la liste des dix
personnes les plus recherchées en 1970
c'était dans le contexte du
développement d'un programme de contre
espionnage comme on appelait cela quand
elle prend qui ciblait particulièrement
les militants noirs
je n'étais pas la seule femme
cela a touché également beaucoup de
membres des black panthers
j'en faisais partie mais j'étais aussi
membre du parti communiste
il est certain que les black panthers
étaient la cible principale
elle avait été qualifiée de menace la
plus dangereuse pour la nation par john
edgar hoover le chef du fbi à l'époque
mais je voudrais souligner qu'à 7h à
courre j'ai toujours envie et habite à
cuba oise a été désigné il ya quelques
années comme l'un des dix terroristes
les plus dangereux au monde continuent à
utiliser son pouvoir pour identifier et
faire obstacle à ceux qui cherchent à
susciter des changements radicaux dans
ce pays il me semble qu'elle a été mis
sur cette liste sous l'administration
obama oui absolument c'était sous
l'administration obama
nous passerons à son vice-président joe
biden dans un instant vous avez parlé du
communisme et vous avez aussi employer
l'expression capitalisme raciale le rôle
de révolutionnaire at il évolué depuis
selon vous il s'agissait de vouloir
changer la société pour un monde où l'on
répondrait aux besoins et aux intérêts
du peuple
j'utilise l'expression capitalisme
raciale qui a été introduite par le
professeur afro américain cédric
robinson un politologue qui se
spécialisait dans les études afro
américaine et qui a souligné que le
capitalisme avait toujours été associée
au racisme dès le départ et jusqu'à
présent autrement dit il ne faut pas
considérer le racisme et le capitalisme
comme deux phénomènes distincts car ils
sont interdépendants
cependant il me semble que le moment
décisif est venu non seulement dans
l'histoire américaine mais dans
l'histoire mondiale
nous avons tous été témoins du lynchage
de georges floyd et cela s'est produit à
un moment où le monde était en
confinement afin d'éviter de propager le
politiste la lutte contre le lynchage et
la violence raciste a eu une très longue
histoire
elle remonte à la période qui suit
immédiatement l'esclave âge je veux dire
qu'on attendait depuis longtemps que ce
moment arrive mais je crois que personne
ne s'attendait à ce que les choses se
déroulent comme ça mais il ya une
certaine convergence
on a vu que le racisme structurel avait
rendu les communautés noires et
latino-américaines plus vulnérables
coronavirus mais en même temps il y a eu
non seulement le meurtre épouvantable de
genre ou floyd mais encore l'assassinât
d'un mode à berry debré ona taylor et de
tony mcdaid ce qui est important
aujourd'hui est que les gens se
concertent sur des enjeux structurels il
ne demande pas que des policiers
particuliers soient traduits en justice
il appelle à démilitariser à faire des
coupes dans les financements de la
police a démantelé la police
oui cela semble vraiment être un
tournant il n'y a pas si longtemps ruth
bader ginsburg juge de la cour suprême a
déclaré que la vedette sportive colline
copernic avait agi stupidement et fait
preuve d'irrespect en mettant à genoux à
terre et maintenant nous voyons le
comité national démocrate faire la même
chose
qu'avez-vous ressenti en voyant nancy
pelosi et d'autres vêtus de kanté
traditionnel ghanéen comme kwame nkrumah
qui emportait aussi avant d'être
renversé par la cia
eh bien c'était assez bizarre bien sûr
mais quand j'ai analysé cela j'ai vu un
impact des mouvements de masse
l'influencent des protestataires
la solidarité que cet acte était censé
démontrer c'est la solidarité que des
millions de gens ont réclamé dans les
rues mais il ne fait aucun doute qu'ils
ont beaucoup plus à faire que de mettre
simplement un genou à terre comme l'a
fait colline catanic beaucoup plus que
de simplement porter un kent et on le
verra ce qui arrivera dans la terrière
dernière en écosse a voté en faveur de
l'arrêt des exportations de gaz
lacrymogènes de balles en caoutchouc et
de boucliers anti-émeutes vers les états
unis
estimez-vous que d'autres pays devraient
cesser de vendre du matériel antiémeutes
aux états unis après tout ce que nous
avons vu lors des manifestations
certainement
il me semble important de noter là qu'en
2014 dans le contexte du soulèvement de
ferguson
la militarisation de la police
américaine a été évidente il s'est avéré
que le gaz lacrymogènes utilisés en
palestine occupée et est le même qu'on
utilisait à ferguson nous avons appris
que de nombreux services de police
américains y compris les plus petits
tels que le service de police de
ferguson avait été formé par l'armée
israélienne pour mener des opérations
anti insurrectionnelles
j'ai aussi entendu dire que la police de
minneapolis avait reçu une formation
israélienne
je ne suis pas sûr que cela concerne les
policiers accusés du meurtre de george
frey
mais il me semble qu'il ne faut pas
oublier qu'il existe un lien important
entre les confrontations aux états unis
et en palestine
on a parlé de ce lien dans les années 60
puis en 2014 est il qu'aujourd'hui aussi
le souligner mais qu'y at il de si
important avec la palestine
l'union européenne se prononce contre le
mouvement de boycott désinvestissement
et de sanctions
au royaume uni le secrétaire aux
affaires étrangères du cabinet fantôme
des clark condamné les atrocités
commises par le gouvernement israélien
est un acte antisémite
en quoi la palestine est elle concernée
ici la palestine nous a beaucoup
enseigné sur la résistance et
l'endurance et nous avons également
beaucoup appris sur le complexe carcéral
industrielle en observant la palestine
et comment elle fait face aux
technologies carcéral développé par
israël il existe depuis très longtemps
des liens de solidarité entre les
palestiniens qui sont sur leur
territoire et les populations noires qui
même leur lutte aux états unis
alors quand j'étais moi même en prison
je recevais de nombreux messages de
solidarité de la part de prisonniers
politiques palestiniens
il est temps de parler de l'absurdité
absolue de l'idée selon laquelle sa
critique des politiques et des pratiques
des états nations telles qu israël est
une forme d'antisémitisme joue
d'ailleurs beaucoup de juifs vivant en
israël sont engagés dans la lutte pour
la solidarité avec la palestine
bds n'est qu'une campagne de boycott de
désinvestissement et de sanctions
c'est donc un mouvement non violent et
la façon de ce mouvement est présenté
par certaines forces dans le monde doit
être analysée est contestée nous
inviterons l'ambassadeur israélien dans
notre émission pour qu'il réponde à
certaines des choses que vous avez
évoquées il me semble que le
gouvernement israélien admet démolir des
maisons
nous allons faire une pause avant de
poursuivre notre entretien avec la black
panther angela davis
[Musique]
voir que nous sommes de retour avec
l'une des militantes et plus influentes
du siècle passé angela davis les
représentants de la police au niveau
local et au niveau de l'état disent que
la réponse aux protestations suscitée
par l'assassinât de georges floyd ne
peut être comparée aux mesures prises
par exemple contre move en 1985 à
philadelphie il y avait alors eu des
enfants morts des bombardements aériens
de maison etc
pensez vous que les choses se passent
mieux de nos jours la situation s'est
améliorée en ce sens que nous en savons
plus nous pouvons analyser les choses de
manière plus efficace et comprendre la
signification des activités policières
auquel la population fait face depuis
très longtemps
il est important de se rappeler que
l'héritage de l'esclavagé fait partie
des principes du maintien de l'ordre
d'aujourd'hui il y avait des patrouilles
qui opérait à l'époque de l'esclavagé
pour opprimer les esclaves puis les lois
racistes qui ont suivi ainsi que la
façon dont les forces de l'ordre ont été
utilisées pour commettre d'horribles
lynchage aujourd'hui nous sommes dans
une meilleure situation parce que nous
sommes conscients du caractère
institutionnel du racisme nous ne disons
pas seulement que certains individus
sont responsables de certains crimes
odieux désigne les systèmes des
structures cette manière de pointe du
doigt le racisme structurel le racisme
institutionnel le racisme étatique est
un phénomène relativement nouveau et
c'est exactement cela qui fait que ce
moment historique
et si particulier mais malgré une telle
prise de conscience l'augmentation des
budgets de la police semble toujours
astronomiques
le budget du département de police de
new york est de 6 milliards de dollars
soit plus que le budget de la défense du
vietnam
il faut tout de même rappeler que c'est
un pays qui a vaincu les états unis
qu'est ce qui se cache derrière les
budgets colossaux de la police l'accent
a été mis sur la police et
l'emprisonnement ce qui a conduit à
l'incarcération de masse et le racisme
en est à l'origine
l'accent est mis sur la loi et l'ordre
au lieu de prêter attention aux besoins
des minorités de couleurs et je voudrais
faire remarquer que nous faisons
aujourd'hui ce qui aurait dû être fait
immédiatement à la fin de l'époque que
l' esclavage
je parle de tous ces processus
permettant de garantir aux gens qui
étaient auparavant des esclaves le
peuple autochtone soumis aux effets
génocidaire de la colonisation aux
communautés latino américaine des
efforts qui aurait dû être fait depuis
longtemps pour comprendre quels
changements sont nécessaires dans notre
société afin d'assurer l'égalité et la
justice pour tous en particulier en ce
qui concerne les questions de justice
économique et raciales et d'égalité des
sexes
vous avez mentionné l'incarcération de
masse peut-être que ça ne concerne pas
le comité national démocrate en lui-même
mais sapin considère byden comme la
personnification de ce phénomène
que direz vous à ceux qui voteront pour
baden en novembre je ne suis pas très
optimiste concernant byden à l'avenir
nous devons nous débarrasser du système
bipartite dont les deux parties sont
trop étroitement lié au capitalisme
d'entreprise
mais c'est certainement un objectif sur
le long terme et il reste moins de cinq
mois avant les prochaines élections
le but de ces élections n'est pas selon
moi de choisir le candidat qui nous
mènera dans la bonne direction
mais de soutenir le candidat pourrait
forcer à donner une plus grande liberté
d'action aux mouvements antiracistes en
évolution byden est en grande partie une
option problématique et pas seulement en
raison de son passé et du rôle qu'il a
joué dans l'augmentation du taux
d'incarcération il a clairement indiqué
qu'il s'opposait au démantèlement de la
police alors que c'est exactement ce
dont nous avons besoin quand il est
nécessaire de repenser la notion de
sécurité publique
mais je le souligne mais byden est
beaucoup plus susceptibles de prendre
les exigences du grand public au sérieux
que le président en exercice
lors des élections qui auront lieu en
novembre
nous devons voter non pas pour le
meilleur candidat mais plutôt voter pour
ou contre nous mêmes et à mon avis si on
veut voter pour nous mêmes nous serons
obligés de mener campagne et voté pour
ben laden
donc vous ne pensez pas que ces
manifestations mèneront à la création
d'un nouveau parti politique pour lequel
voté en novembre
non personnellement je ne le pense pas
mais qui sait ce qui peut arriver
créé en partie exige quand même beaucoup
de temps nous parlons de nouveau par qui
ils apparaissent mais pour former un
parti qui répondrait aux intérêts du
grand public et disposerez des
ressources nécessaires pour obtenir
suffisamment de soutien électoral pour
vaincre donne un truc c'est une autre
affaire
vous plaidez pour des coupes dans les
financements de la police et l'abolition
de la prison comment vit-on dans un pays
qui proportionnellement envoie en prison
plus de gens que mao tsé toung ou
staline à leur époque
je participe au mouvement contre
l'incarcération depuis les années 1970
je me suis engagé dans cette lutte dans
des mouvements pour la libération de
prisonniers politiques pour maxwell que
lolita l'hébreu ou bobby seale des black
panthers 1 c'est beaucoup d'entre nous
appellent à supprimer les prisons depuis
des décennies de manière générale mon
initiation à l'idée d'abolition de ses
institutions a commencé avec le
soulèvement qui a eu lieu en 1971 dans
la prison d'atika alors que j'étais
encore moi-même en détention le racisme
de nous savons qu'il est le moteur du
système policier américain est tout
aussi inhérents au système carcéral et
il est également à l'origine de ce qu'on
appelle incarcération de masse sans les
appels à l'abolition des forces de
maintien de l'ordre sous leur forme
actuelle font écho aux idées exprimées
depuis des décennies aux appels à
l'abolition de prison nous appelons à
supprimer les prisons parce qu'elles ne
sont que des décharges où l'on jette des
gens mais ce n'est que le résultat de
l'incapacité de la société à faire face
aux problèmes de pauvreté de santé
physique et mentale d'éducation etc
pourquoi est ce si difficile
mumia abu jamal est toujours en prison
tout comme leonard peltier
pourquoi n'at-on pas arriver au fil des
décennies à faire libérer ceux qui sont
considérés comme prisonnier politique
aux etats unis
[Musique]
cela montre à quel point ces
institutions sont puissantes à quel
point les services de police et les
syndicats policiers sont forts combien
abu jamal et leonard peltier qui
continuent à dépérir en prison
précisément parce qu'ils s'opposaient
systématiquement aux structures
policières américaines à somme j'espère
que les nombreuses critiques dont la
police fait aujourd'hui l'objet vont
constituer une ouverture permettant de
demander la libération et de leonard et
monia votre nom est connu dans le monde
entier et notamment dans les pays du sud
rhône nous venons d'apprendre que les
services de sécurité britanniques
utilisez votre image peut-être pour
séduire en tout cas pour promouvoir leur
campagne à blé ce touch afin de susciter
un débat progressistes sur facebook et
instagram
qu'est ce que cela vous fait d'avoir été
entraîné dans cette intervention des
services de sécurité du royaume uni cela
ne m'étonne pas il est important de se
rendre compte que toutes sortes de
stratégies sont employés et seront
employées afin d'arrêter la vague de
résistance globale
j'espère que les gens comprendront que
ce sont des mesures désespérées car les
politiques des gouvernements britannique
et américain tente désespérément de
préserver un passé fait de racisme et de
pratiques anti travailliste de misogynie
et d'injustice environnementale
vannes mais angie est 16 bat c mais à
mon avis les jeunes qui protestent
aujourd'hui représente un avenir
différent et la seule chose que je peux
dire c'est que je souhaite qu'ils
l'emportent
une dernière question pour terminer des
statuts impérialistes sont renversés
partout dans le monde
on entend souvent les mots célèbres de
malcom x par tous les moyens nécessaires
comment peut-on interpréter cette phrase
55 ans après l'assassinât de malcom x
âge à l'époque quand malcom x a prononcé
ces mots par tous les moyens nécessaires
il voulait montrer notre détermination
absolue à renverser le racisme et
supprimer les inégalités comme toutes
les formes d'injustice
je crois qu'on peut continuer à utiliser
cette phrase de nos jours le thé même
que tant de personnes soient sortis dans
la rue en pleine pandémie de corona des
russes est le signe d'une grande passion
cela montre qu'il ya une volonté
collective de changement à mon avis les
gens prennent conscience d'à quel point
le passé définit le présent et commence
à comprendre que tout ce qu'on fait
aujourd'hui est quelque chose qu'on a
longtemps attendu s'opposer au racisme
et à la violence policière signifie
faire face à l' héritage séculaire du
racisme ce qu'il y ait un risque de
dérive qu'on profite du mouvement black
live matters on a vu par exemple joe
biden aux funérailles de jack floyd la
célèbre dichotomie house negro versus
fine negro existe-t-elle toujours bien
sûr qu'on assiste toujours à des
tentatives d'exploiter notre lutte
en un sens on peut dire que quand de
telles tentatives ont eu lieu nous
devons reconnaître notre succès si des
gens qui sont au pouvoir cherche
désespérément à s'identifier à ce prix
même sept aps lutte afin d'en modifier
la trajectoire chase mais je crois aussi
que beaucoup en sont conscients et je
salue ces actes de la part des gens au
pouvoir d'un nous voyons que nous avons
défié leur hégémonie et si nous y
parvenons nous serons capables de
résister collectivement à la
prédominance du passé et à entamer notre
chemin vers un futur plus émancipateur
[Musique]